[Musik]
es ist gerade einfach 80 49 am morgen
schon 22 grad
michael c heute erfreuen oder szenen den
allerdings wurde jedenfalls vor tagen
ein paket nicht missachten schützen
beschleunigen
das war einigen wochen in den usa und
kommt jetzt langsam hat deutschland so
dass wenn ich einkaufen gehe ich einfach
durch die regale sie mir alles mit was
energie weil sie morgen einfach
verdammten trinken aber apfel ananas
spinat und ihr mich verarschen das
klingt sehr ich mich warum wir das tun
sagte sie ich mir vor zwei wochen bei
amazon bestellt haben weil die wie bei
einem von mir tatsächlich gesehen habe
der mann ihren quellen sagen
eine erste lesung 21 fitte spieler mit
wird was ist das weiß ja auch nicht
überhaupt genommen hätte mir das so
gesagt und dafür in die hand genommen
man kann halt reden und es hat mich auf
sich zu drehen ihr seid in der zweiten
reihe stark entwickeln dass der wert von
unglaublich viele kugellager und wenn
wir das einmal so dreht ihr schon wo
freunde entlang der leyen endlich mal
ein hardware nicht genau wie lange ich
glaube das lenken konnte war vier
minuten und greifen so alle charaktere
bewusst langsam machen und jetzt aber
doch andré ist auf jeden fall irgendein
spiel gezeigt mit unendlich vielen
kugellager und ich habe da mal bestellt
bei amazon
irgendwie glaube in euro oder irgendwie
so und ich mein ding noch irgendwas
kürze vom wegen irgendwie licht aus wenn
oder irgendwelche töne machen oder so
dass er vielleicht ganz in ordnung
solche spielzeug den euro ist auch nicht
die welt den euro aber das ding kann
nicht ausdehnen und meistens auch schon
carports normalerweise sehen diese arme
so aus also das dauert einfach seine
linie ist dieses eine dinge einfach
schon so halbe raus ich hab das halt
wirklich einfach nur 34 mal gedreht und
fester in die hand genommen dass die
wichtigen hier raus also keine ahnung
warum amerika ging und vielleicht
irgendwie gekommen youtube machen könnte
und auch mit mark und dessen übernehmen
und nicht eingefallen weil gibt 210 euro
für dieses und das einzige machen
verleitet uns drehen
er hörte keine gesamtsicht über die
widgets bilder machen werde
die langstrecke macht was ihr gefällt
weil mein traum vom profi cabrio wetter
residenten gerade schreibt die uhr 11
uhr und wir haben zwar auf 24 grad wird
heute übrigens auch noch passieren wir
dass ich nachher debatten ab oder die
videos aufnehmen und nach hin auf einem
see fahren mit auch weiter köln ist so
verdammt schön wenn das wetter anhalten
fachleute der hkd nicht abholen musste
in düsseldorf wies jetzt auch da und
jetzt gibt ab zu einer freundin die in
oberkassel und keine ahnung oder
planänderungen dahin wohnt die ich bin
gerade hier und köln es hier unten und
zierte schon alles voll mit verkehr teil
typisch köln/düsseldorf verkehr immer
und wenn ich jetzt dahin fahren würde
wäre hier ein autounfall dahin wäre
schon überall heute fahre ich lieber
nicht herum überall und baustellen und
wenn ich jetzt wie die nach oberkassel
rhein fahren würde dann würde ich wieder
40 minuten raus fahren aber ich bin
ehrlich gesagt ich bin ein guter freund
als ich nachhaltig vom roten macht euch
mal ein oder zwei minuten vorher ab
dort wird er gehen wir angekommen und
werden hier dennis gekommen und wenn
nach alter steigen wenn das hier
mitgebracht das kommt verwechseln in
schottland mitgebracht das im shop kommt
dass sie kommt den schatten
noch dazu launischen werden aber ich
gucke jetzt etwa die muster 13 gehört
dass ihr neues gerade raus kommt der
beschreibung hohen leute den kameras
die eingegangenen angekommen am
fühlinger see aber irgendwie
panikattacken da selbst mal sebastian
davon auf jeden fall und die regattabahn
wir haben fehler gemacht und schirm zur
erschließung wieder zurück auf dem
wasser ziehen also für 1 mw was hat ja
ein bisschen belästigt ich habe mich
krass gerecht im januar schwer
körperlich misshandelt und würde bloss
war der launischen lukas ott am ersten
sechsten
was tust du dicker und schmutzig stern
bleibt nicht mehr aufstehen muss man die
tür aufmachen muss und ihr seht ihr auch
schon vorher an der wand aber die
menschen zutiefst müssen höher ein paar
sekunden später
ich hoffe diese weise der hand zu
verdienen
die minister mit
die hürden und sich auf einer höhe
und jetzt kommen wir zum teil meine
damen und herren sind in bonn ist er mit
und lange vorbereit und war ihre
entscheidung meine damen und herren wir
es gerade sein da wie wir denn da
doch doch getan
[Gelächter]
aber wenn jetzt abbrechen oder strafen e
mail an die adresse für köhler laser
luca letzten mal meinen blog nachfragen
mich sehr viele leute e ducati schaffst
du überhaupt ist ein kaktus innerhalb
von kürzester zeit so viel gewachsen ist
immer mit bier gibt es war eigentlich
gerade nur fünf bier aufgemacht aber
darauf erst mal ein bisschen bohlweg bei
mädchen vor was ich mache
[Musik]
sporty club geschafft und jetzt geben
wir hinterher
der kupon liege stadttoren den erste
worte von jahren
also was hältst du von denen jetzt
männer das beste was man damit tun kann
hatte die hilfe drehen ist genau die
waffe die ich mich auch frage das heißen
feuer bin ich auch eigentlich sebastian
vollkommen dunkel
[Musik]
das leben schwer auch weil ich diesen
komischen fischland ramsauer vor zum
stopfen des traktor wohnung angekommen
beim linie vom flughafen abholen wenn
man den schreibblock wird was sagen okay
danke bist du glücklich wieder in köln
zu sein wie gesehen hat haben den markt
vom flughafen abgeholt ein paar freunde
von mir sind gerade noch an einer kirche
trinken ich habe keine ahnung warum und
wie man das macht und wo das ist aber
ich gehe erst mal hinkriegen
die neben verstehen werden wieder mit
meinem iphone gefilmt seien die einzige
komplett gemacht hat für diesen blog
[Musik]
ich war die krasse ausnahme lukas toll
gemacht ich hoffe einfach trotz der
großen kreisstadt untertitel stellten
aber ich hoffe ich dass der blogger
trotzdem gefallen
[Musik]